I'm right up here where you live up  there I don't understand how we've never  met I've probably skated by your house  like every day on the wid practice that  you wouldn't want to do something  sometime would you I could pay for your  night this your first live show yes  really likes you I can tell  I am not comfortable with him not  knowing what should I have said hey by  the way if the Sun hits my skin I could  die she's sick Katie we please just talk  to me  this isn't something you can just not  tell me I'm so sorry but we're not the  couple who doesn't try  every day I waited for you to walk by my  window if I just looked up we could have  been together this whole time  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you